so our vision was to create a tool that
would very easily integrate with all of
the different data sources but all of
the most common data sources bring the
data together do what is called identity
resolution or see that um you know
Michael is the same Michael on the
website and on the CLM and so on and
then
um allow business professionals to do
this very deep quantitative analysis so
with machine learning and statistical
modeling in order to get real insights
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
foreign
ERS I'm with Arielle geifman today
co-founder and cro of dealtail the
revenue science company Arielle was the
CEO of dltel from founding until the
acquisition by Vianney at the beginning
of 2022 he is an avid entrepreneur and
an expert in Tech go to market
[Applause]
Ariel geissman welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being with
me today how are you
[Music]
I'm doing well Michael how are you
doing very well now that now that we're
speaking because today I'm gonna get to
learn not just about your own
entrepreneurial Journey which it looks
quite a incredible having been in so
many different organizations in a
variety of different positions involving
entrepreneurial positions consultancy
positions marketing positions uh and so
where we're gonna unpack a little bit
about yourself and your journey and then
dive into the world of Revenue Styles
which I'm really excited to hear about
how no code or low code Solutions can
help different organizations around the
world with their revenue science and
decision-making processes Ariel tell me
a little bit about how you perceive how
your journey unfolded and how you found
yourself in this world
uh sure so um you know I was
um I think I always had the
entrepreneurial State all the way from
childhood when I was I was the guy when
you know with the um lemonade stand and
later and you know always kind of
dreaming to
um you know start businesses and grow
them and so I always
um had the urge to do something
um amazing
um but
um you know I didn't start as an
entrepreneur I actually
um you know started as a journalist so
in my military service I went to uh
Israeli military radio
and then you know after I am graduated
from my um bachelor's degree I went to
uh pursue an MBA at University of
Virginia in the states and I think there
um like all
um Israelis uh kind of in the same
career path I went to do the Consulting
gig and so I worked for a large
consulting firm in the states and worked
with um
um large Enterprise customers who um you
know were looking for you know a lot of
quantitative advice around how to
optimize the go to market incentive
compensation a lot of very interesting
projects and I think that was a real
eye-opener towards
um uh towards Big Business and it took
me and I came back to Israel took me a
little bit of time to you know gather
gather the college needed to do my own
thing but after a few years I started my
own company and
and then it was more of a consulting
company and where I consulted to a lot
of different startups and only after
that I actually had the um had the
opportunity to meet some amazing
co-founders and style detail which was
my first product Centric company
tell me about dealtail Revenue science
what is that about
and so
um at the intern we actually
um as I
um as I walked and consulted different
organizations I've noticed that it's um
there's kind of a theme uh that um while
we always think that organizations are
very data-driven especially on their go
to market side uh the real truth is that
um you know it's today it's very very
challenging to actually do the analysis
that you need in order to be successful
and there are a few challenges in the
space the first one is that the data is
spread across different platforms across
different uh Thanos so that's the
website and that the CLM and the
marketing Automation and then a lot of
other tools or databases that the
organizations use and so the data is
spread out and and then there is another
there's another which is the skill Gap
because the business professionals are
actually
um needing this analysis or wanting to
do this analysis are not very skilled at
writing SQL code so it's very hard for
them to actually bring the data and then
unit fight and aware that would allow
them to to get insights and they're also
not very familiar with and you know a
lot of the data science techniques that
are needed in order to get from you know
the raw data into insights so our vision
was to create a tool that would very
easily integrate with all of the
different data sources but all of the
most common data sources bring the data
together do what is called identity
resolution or see that um you know
Michael is the same Michael on the
website and on the CLM and so on and
then
um allow business professionals to do
this very deep quality everyone Alex
says or with machine learning and
statistical modeling in order to get
real insights and that was the vision
and
um
the vision and there were a few
pillars that were key you know to
realize that the first one was no code
again we wanted to go to the business
professionals the people who
um you know didn't know how to write
code or didn't have time or didn't even
want to know the second thing was to be
able to you know do it very very quickly
so in terms of our benchmarks we wanted
to be up and running within a day if you
uh if you're a little bit familiar with
data projects usually they take months
sometimes you know six months to a year
in order to
um get materialized and so we wanted to
do it within a day and the last thing is
to actually remove the barrier to entry
it's also allowing smaller organizations
to do the same type of analysis that
large organizations can do
um
so at the beginning and when you
actually start a company it's a real
challenge because
um you want to create something that is
truly revolutionary in the um in this
space
but then you know it's uh basically four
entrepreneurs and you know needing to
create a tool that is takes many hours
and I would say very long many years of
um you know walking walking order to
create and then you need to find some
um ways to and to move faster and create
an MVP that would allow you to prove
that there is a product Market Street
here
what was the
what did you learn about the consumer
Behavior or the key insights that you've
brought together
as you were testing out dealtail in the
first place
so we learned a few things we learned
that
um
companies uh organizations
you know they have a real mean
for analytics
um which is
um
you know kind of gathering the data and
being able to drive meaningful insights
um another thing that we learned about
our consumers is that there is the
challenge of maybe getting the data and
doing the analysis and getting the
insights but then there is another whole
new challenge of actually doing the
change management in order to put these
insights into into work where you know
they and Champion so the people doing
the analysis then they need to go and
spread Awards and you know make sure
that and you know people are actually
um able to
um
bring the insights and make them into
business value
and how do you follow through taking
insights that you're bringing together
through the integration of the data in
your own algorithms how do you then how
do you then make that leap towards the
business value that perhaps is more
fine-tuned to businesses or perhaps it's
or maybe it's not it's fine-tuned as I
think I mean well how how do you close
that loop with the business value
a great question so I think the um the
key here is simplicity so maybe you're
doing a very sophisticated analysis okay
for example one of our attribution
models uses a Markov chains in order to
calculate the incremental value on and
you know marketing campaigns and touch
points because at the end of the day we
need to give it to our customer in a
very simple and understandable way for
them to be able to take it and you know
share it across the organization and see
how they can actually make it work for
them
right and so even that process of of
getting how did how do you how what was
the process that you had to go through
to take a product that you know it's
kind of in a blue ocean there's so many
different things that it can do and you
can look at how do you what what steps
did you do running the company that
helped you both simplify not necessarily
the algorithm the tech but to simplify
the user experience of the ones that are
using it
so
um I think as a small company one of the
most important thing was Focus so you
need to there are a lot of problems that
we can solve but you need to focus on
the one or two that are most pressing to
your customers and that they're willing
to pay for and that you can actually
solve for them on in a scalable manner
with your limited resources
so now two things in play here first of
all
um you need to see that the important
that you're solving is actually an a
meaningful custom a meaningful problem
for your customer but also on the other
hand it's a problem that you as the
entrepreneur can actually solve within
the resources that you have at hand
otherwise you run out of money before
you actually solve any problems and I
think
um this process of you know getting more
and more focused on the problems that
actually matter uh was what allowed us
to actually do and get a product to
Market that added I think tremendous
value to our customers very very fast
do you remember specifically what were
some of those key features that you've
identified as those big those meaningful
problems that you were focusing on and
you knew that there were a lot of other
things you could do but you were
focusing on those and those are the ones
that got the stickiness
yes so
um we realized that
um there were a few so the first one was
to actually identify
um the customer Journey so
um companies were very good at you know
identifying where customers came from
but they weren't very good at actually
seeing the full customer Journey
especially in cases where they had
multiple touch points so this was a
repaint and and then the other pain was
actually optimizing budgets and so these
two were pains that we identified uh
when we were talking to customers and
when we were showing product and and
quickly we realized that we should be
focusing on effort on
delivering these Solutions and doing it
in a way
um very effective and very fast way
and and what's the connecting that
because those two things are are also uh
quite separate naturally right but what
is sort of the connecting line between
them so so not necessarily so when you
have the customer Journey then you can
apply algorithms in order to optimize it
so you can actually when you know what
the customer touched all the way to
becoming a customer you can actually say
okay this touchpoint is important
Another Touch point is less important so
yeah you can actually calculate things
like our why and allow the customer to
optimize budgets based on nowhere every
dollar works the hardest
that makes sense tell me a little bit
about your own uh your own perspective
as an entrepreneur what did you learn
about yourself throughout this journey
so
um I learned that um
another few things so first of all I
think that um
you know kind of on the um
on the personal side I really like it it
allows you to do a lot of very
interesting things and really the um
the creation of a new idea and bringing
it to life reading it to Market I think
there's something that I really like
about it and this is something that um
you know has been a lot of fun we're
kind of taking things like
um it's like a baby you know seeing it
from the moment that you initially
conceive it all the way to you know
growing up as a as a company you know
bringing more people to
um your vision customers and investors
stakeholders and convincing them I think
there's something that's you know really
allows you to to shine uh as as person
through this process
um I think there's also
um kind of in a way that um
you know in a in a way that um what I
see
um making an impact myself making an
impact I think that entrepreneurship
allows me to
um you know really take my core skills
which is innovation and creative
thinking and put it to play in a very
um uh impactful way in order to
um you know bring something that is is
new and Innovative and solves people's
problems
are there some things that really
surprised you about this uh about this
process that you've gone through you
know things that you you thought of one
thing and all of a sudden you're facing
this entrepreneurial journey and you
realize that there's something that's
dramatically different than what what
you were expecting yourself
um
oh you've probably heard it before
entrepreneurship is a roller coaster so
um one day on top the other day you know
you're having the worst day of your life
um so it's always
um you kind of expect it but when you're
on the roller coaster it's always hard
and it's um
I think the um
as an entrepreneur you have
um
the role of actually
um it's myself and my co-founders you
know doing the impossible so you know
bringing a product to Market
uh with very little budget uh without
the ability to get top talents uh
without any proof customers are asking
who the hell are you and why shouldn't
trust you why should we even
um you know let it touch our data and
employees
um are questioning whether you're going
to be them be there tomorrow so you have
to overcome
so many challenges on a daily basis and
that you know sometimes I am I'm asking
myself whether you know
um I was you can actually make it but I
think this ability to you know
get to these challenges one by one solve
them as you know move the company
forward I think that's what
differentiates good entrepreneurs with
the ones that eventually give up
I love it and so so just following and
closing the loop on on sort of the
reflective piece of the of the
interviews looking back
going on the next Journey let's say you
start another company or if you were to
go back and talk to yourself as you were
starting it out what what are some key
ideas that you would hold really close
and they can be very specific they can
be more generic or mindset related but
what are things that really you would
you would keep close to your heart
so
um before you actually launch I think
preparation is key
so you have to be focused and I think
you need to be
um dedicated as many hours as you can to
doing research I think people have the
perception of
um you know you can change things as you
go but it's much better to actually have
the kind of the rights and or at least
do enough research in order to have
pretty much what you want to do uh when
you start
um I think that dedicating the time in
order to do the research and doing it in
a very slow way going out there speaking
to customers doing mock-ups and
understanding that
um what you're about to deliver actually
delivers value would save you so much
time interesting for station later on
that
um you're gonna appreciate every hour
and that you've spent on it and every
dollar that you've spent on it and I
think that um before you actually you
know launch before you start the raid so
go on a roller coaster and it's better
to come prepared and I think this is um
my biggest advice
Arielle thank you so much this was a
very enjoyable conversation both talking
about detail and revenue science but
also about your own personal journey and
what drives you to detail and the ways
that you're looking now at the journey
that you've been going through and so
very much appreciate your time and your
your energy bringing here and best of
luck with everything else that you're a
part of and thank you very much
thank you very much Michael